>> Tucker: THESE ARE FEARFUL
TIMES IN AMERICAN LIFE,
OBVIOUSLY AMERICANS WORRY THEY
CAN DIE OF THIS DISEASE AND
SOMEONE THEY LOVE COULD DIE IF
THEY LOSE THEIR JOBS AND COULD
BE CRIPPLED PERMANENTLY IN THE
WAKE OF THIS DISASTER, IT’S A
TERRIFYING MOMENT.
IN THAT MOMENT, WE NEED WISDOM
AND STUDY GUIDANCE FROM OUR
LEADERS.
WE NEED ALTRUISM, NEED TO CARE
MORE ABOUT YOU THAN THEY CARE
ABOUT THEMSELVES BUT IN
CONGRESS, THEY DON’T.
THE FOREMOST CONCERN OF SOME
MEMBERS OF SAVING THEIR OWN
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIOS ARE MAKING
STUPID PARTISAN POINTS OR
INDULGING THEIR CREEPY
IDEOLOGICAL OBSESSIONS.
I WONDER WHY CONGRESS HASN’T YET
PASSED A BILL TO HELP THE
COUNTRY SURVIVE THIS?
THAT’S WHY.
DETAILS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PLAN
BECAME OUT TODAY.
PARTS HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PANDEMIC, READ IT AND YOU WILL
FIND DISGUSTING LITTLE HANDOUTS
ADDED BY LOBBYIST.
WORSE, IT IS SUFFUSED WITH CRUEL
BIGOTRY OF IDENTITY POLITICS AT
A TIME WHEN AMERICA IS SO BADLY
DESPERATELY NEEDING TO COME
TOGETHER, DEMOCRATS REMAIN
INTENT ON SPLITTING THIS COUNTRY
INTO WARRING TRIBES.
IS SHOCKING.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT A BILL TODAY,
NANCY PELOSI BLAMES THE POPE.
>> LAST THURSDAY, POPE FRANCIS
OFFERED THE WORLD THIS PRAYER.
"ENLIGHTEN THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE COMMON GOOD SO THEY MIGHT
KNOW HOW TO CARE THOSE ENTRUSTED
TO THEIR RESPONSIBILITY.
"TODAY, HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
UNVEILING THE RESPONSIBILITY
ACT, A BILL THAT TAKES
RESPONSIBLY FOR THE HEALTH OF
WORKERS.
TO PUT CORPORATIONS FIRST, BUT
BECAUSE OF THE INSISTENCE A
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER AND
DEMOCRATS, PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE.
>> Tucker: EVEN BY WASHINGTON
STANDARDS, SHAMELESSNESS LIKE
THAT, QUOTING THE POPE.
IS CURRENTLY MORE THAN 1400
PAGES, NOT THAT LONG BECAUSE
IT’S A FINELY TUNED FIX, HOUSE
DEMOCRATS HAVE CRAMMED IT WITH
TOTALLY UNRELATED POLITICAL
PRIORITIES.
STOKING RACIAL DIVISION AS
USUAL, GLOBAL WARMING, OPEN
BORDERS.
HE SHOULD READ IT.
HERE IS JUST SOME OF WHAT YOU
WILL FIND IF YOU DO.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE EVERY
CORPORATION THAT RECEIVES
CORONAVIRUS AID TO HAVE OFFICERS
AND A BUDGET DEDICATED TO
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
INITIATIVES FOR A MINIMUM OF
FIVE YEARS AFTER THEY GET THE
MONEY BECAUSE THAT’S GOING TO
KEEP AMERICA HEALTHY AND
PROSPEROUS.
MORE BEAN COUNTERS MAKING SURE
YOU ARE THE RIGHT COLOR BEFORE
THEY GIVE YOU A JOB.
COMPANIES WOULD ALSO HAVE TO
PRODUCE ELABORATE RACIAL REPORTS
FOR THE GOVERNMENT LISTING THE
SKIN COLOR AND THE OF THEIR
OFFICERS AND BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS.
THEY HAVE TO PROVE THEY GIVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO FIRMS OWNED BY
WOMEN AND NONWHITES AND OF
COURSE HOW MUCH THEY SPEND ON
DIVERSITY INITIATIVES.
IN ALL, THIS BILL USES THE WORD
DIVERSE OR DIVERSITY MORE THAN
60 TIMES.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE PANDEMIC THAT MIGHT KILL
YOU?
NOT ONE THING.
JUST MORE UGLY RACE POLITICS,
THE KIND THEY SPECIALIZE IN.
DEMOCRATS THINK THAT’S MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW AND THEN IT
GETS WORSE THAN THAT.
THE BILL ALLOCATES $300 MILLION
FOR HIRING EXPERTS TO MANAGE
CORONAVIRUS PREPARATION AND
RESPONSE.
AS HER CRITICAL JOBS BUT INSTEAD
OF LOOKING FOR THE MOST
QUALIFIED PEOPLE AT A TIME OF
NATIONAL EMERGENCY FROM THE ONLY
CRITERIA RIGHT NOW ARE YOU
QUALIFIED INSTEAD OF THAT, IT
ORDERS EMPLOYEES BE CHOSEN ON
THE BASIS OF THEIR RACE AND
DISABILITY STATUS.
THIS IS DANGEROUS INSANITY.
WHO CARES WHAT COLOR YOUR
SCIENTISTS ARE?
BUT IT GOES ON.
THE BILL WOULD MANDATE THAT ALL
50 STATES HAVE AN EARLY VOTER
PERIOD AS WELL AS SAME-DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION.
Y?
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THOSE CHANGES
WOULD GIVE THEM AN ELECTORAL
ADVANTAGE.
WOULD EXPAND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES.
THAT IS LIKELY THE GROUP LEAST
THREATENED BY THE EFFECT OF
CORONAVIRUS.
AND THIS IS THE REAL POINT, THE
MOST FAITHFUL DEMOCRATIC VOTING
BLOCK.
ON MATTERS OF POLICY, THE BILL
DOESN’T EVEN TRY.
SHOULD THE AIRLINES GET A
FEDERAL BAILOUT?
THAT’S AN ACTUAL QUESTION, YOU
COULD PICK EITHER SIDE.
TOO SERIOUS FOR THEM.
INSTEAD, IT WOULD REQUIRE ANY
AIRLINE THAT TAKES FEDERAL MONEY
OFFSET THEIR CARBON EMISSIONS
WITHIN FIVE YEARS BECAUSE
CLIMATE ACTIVISM IS WAY MORE
IMPORTANT THAN A DISEASE THAT
COULD KILL YOUR FAMILY NEXT
WEEK.
AND THEN THERE IS THIS.
THE HOUSE VERSION OF THE BILL
INCLUDE SPECIAL PROVISIONS TO
PROTECT FOREIGN NATIONALS
WORKING HERE IN THE U.S.
SO WE ARE STARING DOWN THE
BARREL OF THE MOST PROFOUND
EMPLOYMENT CRISIS OF OUR
LIFETIME, NOT AN EXAGGERATION
AND WHAT ARE DEMOCRATS DOING?
TRYING TO AUTOMATICALLY RENEW
VISAS AND WORK PERMITS FROM ALL
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE THEIR JOBS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
WAY MORE IMPORTANT THAN YOURS.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE REPLACING
YOU ARE SECURE AND HAPPY.
THE WHOLE THING DEFIES BELIEF
AND THAT’S NOT A PARTISAN
OBSERVATION.
AGAIN, READ IT.
THE REPUBLICAN VERSION OF THE
BILL IS NOT THAT AWFUL, NOTHING
COULD BE THAT AWFUL BUT WE WANT
TO BE FAIR AND TELL YOU
EVERYTHING GOING ON TONIGHT ON
CAPITOL HILL CAPITOL HILL.
ACCORDING TO AN INFORMED SOURCE
THAT WE SPOKE TO, SOME SENATE
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO KILL
THE REQUIREMENT TO COMPANIES
THAT RECEIVED BAILOUT FUNDS STOP
SENDING AMERICAN JOBS OVERSEAS.
WHY WOULD THEY DO SOMETHING LIKE